[Music]
in fake healthy news fake coffee like a
bodybuilder submitted by tip is a snap
with to seize time huh
what kind of smack like a payday I love
Hades but no one really talks about
paydays they talk about Snickers we'll
have you guys what discontinued it but
it was the [ __ ] [ __ ] every time I go
to the grocery store is okay payday is
like just peanuts yeah you Garrett
caramel nougat nougat nougat
it's nougat what's the difference
between caramel nougat it tastes
different
being green the entire ingredients I
thought it was a caramel filling with
the peanut outer crust there's my big
caramel on it but it's nougat inside do
you guys like Toblerone I don't know no
I don't like that I like Rollo's
depending if it's a squirrel anyway I
like give me no wrong yeah Tobler roan
I just know like the name Toblerone
isn't some after book man it is though
here our 11th lose you think are healthy
but actually aren't don't tell me what I
think there's no all of these you do cuz
you read the article you cheer no no I
studied food so much that I know
everything that's healthy yet I just
don't eat it alright name it I don't
know what this articles talking about
specifically but I guarantee I already
knew that it was my test test - lemon I
tell us the test us to see if we know if
it's healthy or not I want to just know
all of them are not yeah oh oh they just
sort of make some [ __ ] up and then add
some [ __ ] that is and it tell us I know
what one of them is already cuz you saw
my laptop screen what is it know again
I see your laptop I can't see what it is
here we're gonna say like a sandwich no
cuz like you know like they were doing
there's like all this stuff about what's
a heart-healthy fat what's not remember
there was that huge coconut oil craze
that everybody just email bunch of
coconut oil
I'm pretty sure that's going to be on
there I don't know about veggies though
that's like [ __ ] vegan girls that
like to pop Molly all day talk about
health the raves like you can't drink
yeah
but then they'll be smoking cigarettes
yeah they're like smoking cigarettes Oh
Evie get a [ __ ] let's party girl alcohol
that's messy smells like your armpit
alright alright the first item on this
list is granola bars a lot of people
think there's a lot of sugar there's a
[ __ ] ton of sugar and oil yeah well I
just do that they taste good I think if
it tastes good it's pretty bad for ya
that's literally what it is the general
rule is if it's on a shelf it's bad for
you it needs to be in the produce
section where it's gonna expire if it
lasts more than a week
it's bad for you everyone got a weird
idea what's healthy though well from the
media yeah right yeah it's not their
fault
General Mills if it doesn't expire in a
week it's bad for you yeah except for
spam especially cooking spam is so bad
for you I got so upset when I looked at
a can of spam is the [ __ ] worst that
[ __ ] is the craziest amount of calories
sodium is [ __ ] it's like 30 grams of
fat or one gram of protein that's why
you get spam extra light it's not as
good as the original spam but just don't
get Spain it does the job there's less
cancer in there alright the second thing
on this list is yogurt so unless you're
eating plain Greek yogurt most other
yogurts are gonna be packed with sugar
orange juice any kind of Jamiel both
gifts juice at the same time my milk cuz
it's super [ __ ] sugar they they add
they add sugar too sometimes yeah
and it'll put the peel in it yeah you
need all the
nobody or support like that way cuz the
peel helps you digest all these and
stuff but even if you get a fresh
squeezed orange juice that's still
unhealthy because it's meant to be the
fruit is meant to be eaten with the
fiber and everything and if that [ __ ]
with your insulin levels and [ __ ]
wouldn't unless you up blended the nuts
different yeah but if you've ever had
blended fruit that [ __ ] sucks well you
got to put the whole I drank the juice
like I've been juicing now but I blend
everything idle
I don't like blending a [ __ ] apple
that [ __ ] is just you could add Greek
yogurt very I'll make us some of my
juices oh I love her juice this sweeter
you can't taste any of its pudding I use
almond milk
yuck what I like eating fruits how it is
I don't like blending yeah both of them
and then I put kale and spinach and all
this picture in it I even like it but
you can't taste the other you know for
roll-ups all Apple like the natural not
not okay you doubt my place sugar they
got it schooled of dried fruit yeah the
one that feels like sandpaper that's
just [ __ ] apple juice no I mean
applesauce and then you dry that
[ __ ] then you roll it off the
ceramic I guess it's true so it bottled
fruit smoothie yes yeah so like the
naked or what all of that is horrible
yeah so it's really bad because they're
saying that when fruit is in juice form
a lot of the natural nutrients like the
fiber is stripped away and so any
nutrients are you turning it out of it
it's pretty much gone and it's nothing
but sugar but it's better than drinking
a coke and I think that's why most
people yeah that's how they justify it
yeah they're justifying it based off of
the worst thing they could do instead of
what can I do it's actually better for
me well also to like with these stuff to
like people are having videos like
smoothie drinks right and they're having
a meal with it
these things are supposed to be taken as
a meal yeah that's enough calories to be
already like 400 like 400 calories it's
like chock full of whatever [ __ ] it has
a good decent amount of carbs so if
you're gonna do like a strenuous
activity you need some carbs you could
take that but people are having that
with their
therefore I so it's like you just had
two meals yeah you know I know what that
feels like tastes so good oh yeah I
always get a coke economic order from
fat burger I get a large coke and
cookies in cream shake
cuz it's different you need to have that
well you also probably burn like 2,000
calories in the morning when you weight
workout choking out your friends you
know they tell you to stop you know
that's like that's like if I if I run
eight miles I'm eating a pizza but I
only eat that like once every couple of
miles that's only a slice that's all
you've burned off a slice I mean the
whole peak that's why I'm stuff doesn't
go got it I'll work out twice I see the
problem now I'm burning so many calories
but here's eating three times but
there's no deficit yesterday I was like
oh I'm you know I gotta I'm gonna pick
up some food I'm thinking some about
vegetables so I was like what's good
vegetable trying these vegetables right
and then I started looking at the menu
chow mein rice thanks you know string
bean that was the vegetable I think you
want to keep me fat - I think there's
something going on no you're [ __ ]
magical you don't get that fat amazingly
95 pounds too fast you know Chinese food
too isn't good if you just get one item
you can't just order fried rice and
that's me oh yeah you can actually you
can oh no that is [ __ ] alright it needs
to be a party okay you need to have a
little bit of rice you have a little
vegetable a little meat product and a
little bit of noodle yeah little bit and
you need to eat it for the next couple
of days yeah or just for the rest of the
day yeah eat the whole thing
so another thing on his list is a lot of
things like a cold burrito salad what's
the difference yeah it's just as bad so
though what they're saying here because
it's thinner so they're like oh it's
like less car that's what they think but
in reality it's more carbs because
tortilla or like the wraps themselves
tortillas out how the carbs they are
processed more than just regular bread
so you end up getting more sodium or
trans fat more I never ate a good rap
ever yeah I mean either that [ __ ] is
like the [ __ ]
smack rap for McDonald's something I
never tried it to me it's like [ __ ]
last resort 7-eleven or airport food and
it's like that or a [ __ ] soggy a
sandwich the Wendy's one is really good
see like the the only thing I think I
have an issue with this is that these
foods technically aren't unhealthy foods
it's like a mouse and how people eat it
I think what they're trying to say is
like people that aren't informed they do
think it's healthy so they gain tons of
those exactly so it's always portion
right because if you look at a rap in a
dietary scale it's actually great you
have fiber you have veggies you have
your carb and then you have your protein
if you like a quarter of it that's like
a pretty complete meal like if you get
the subway wrapped like a turkey wrap
it's like super low in calories it has a
decent amount of carbs and had a good
amount of protein problem is there's
like salt or whatever but you don't have
to add any of that stuff to it so it's
actually pretty is actually one of my go
to meals like when I'm on the go I get
like a subway rap so I mean really
depend of how you eat it for me sponsor
rape kit veggie chips those are those
are seen as like oh it's like the
alternative to eating raw vegetables but
that's like someone getting a hamburger
and then there's a pickle side as my
vegetable that's a Barnes that's all the
time okay when Bart needs his veggies
for the day he orders a hamburger and it
has lettuce he's like no I ordered
iceberg lettuce too I ordered food truck
tacos because the onions and cilantro oh
god I haven't had a food truck sounds
good King Haakon acai bowls
I don't like mad sugary nothing but a
lot of sugar but so there's so far I
don't know people eat acai bowls because
it's healthy you know people don't know
what the [ __ ] healthy is do yeah they uh
yeah cuz I just just convinced the
dragon for one is good too because they
let's promote acai with like super high
in antioxidants or whatever but then
it's like trace amounts they just take
one thing they blow it up and then
there's 500 grams of sugar because
they're saying that each ingredient in
an acai bowl by themselves
yes it's healthy like the sake puree or
fruit or granola I guess like
individually but then once you mix it
all together then you're gonna have an
overload of sugar you're just one meal
it's so good it is yeah I see those
bowls as like ice cream I see it as
design I don't I never saw it as like oh
this is healthy you know what's [ __ ]
healthy oatmeal with nothing in water
just boil that [ __ ] eat it with
strawberries you can put some fruit in
it [ __ ] as such no I love it
I eat it as a side oh would you like
what they add sugar milk it does that is
some peasant [ __ ] that is wrong what is
no no what are you cooking you oatmeal
correctly I like it with brown sugar and
butter
sounds good and if you get sliced
almonds and golden raisins she knows
what's up good like or like those punchy
granola or whatever for some texture
like really good three scoops of ice
cream good yeah it's like oatmeal cookie
ice cream yeah with cinnamon yeah but
like oatmeal what brown sugar is like
the and butter and butter it's so
[ __ ] good do you dust a little
cinnamon in there yeah that too
cuz you're allowed to that's healthy
damn it's fine yes what the other foods
are you check out the link in the
description B Haley who gives a [ __ ]
about house dude
[Music]